from windows to paint contractors and
home builders are facing shortages of
supplies they have never seen before a
pandemic related supply chain issue is
to blame for most of these shortages joe
mohler live in henderson near saint rose
parkway and star avenue with a bit more
on this issue joe
[Music]
oh brian whether you're doing a
renovation at your home or you're
looking to build a new house just like
this one here you could see delays from
things like windows to paint lines like
you mentioned and also even flooring now
people in the industry say these delays
are very real and some people are even
dealing with price changes
more recently has seen delays
for freight and shipping vino's flooring
in north las vegas is facing all types
of delays mostly hard surface products
your tiles your
laminates luxury vinyl planks owner nick
bino says they have had to adjust where
they can we're telling a lot of
customers that we can't really guarantee
prices
longer than like 60 to 90 days
because of the
increase in all the different prices
that have been going on over the years
the flooring industry is just one area
of the construction world dealing with
this sort of problem now i'm hearing
heater coils
switch plate covers
paint
us pvc that hodgins is the ceo of the
southern nevada homebuilders association
he says lumber was the problem for a
while but now it's almost everything
else the reasons vary the story i get on
everything that we're talking about here
is william covid we had to shut down our
plans we're trying to get back up again
then see well and something that's fact
right you see all the ships off the
coast of california this all means
construction projects get delayed for
contractors and home builders there's no
way around it
you know some of the builders have
pulled back sales a little bit just to
be able to know that they can put the
house on the ground in the next month
and
fairness to the buyer right
predictability and when they can close
it's it's frustrating how long these
delays will last is unknown bino says if
you are building or planning a project
plan ahead leave yourself plenty of time
to do it
back out here live bino also says if you
are working with a contractor or
designer make sure to check the
availability on those products and it
may be a good idea to try and pick the
products such as the flooring or even
cabinetry as soon as you can reporting
live in henderson joe mohler 8 news now